a sinistra avete un affresco di Pompei
quello che con tutta probabilità e il
sito archeologico più famoso del mondo
mentre a destra avete un selfie scattato
dal perseverance il Rover della NASA
atterrato su Marte lo scorso febbraio e
sicuramente penserete che questi due
mondi siano completamente diversi ma se
vi dicessi con viaggio per marte può
partire proprio la Pompei mi creireste
Beh so che questo può sembrare
incredibile ma è proprio di questo di
cui parleremo stasera e inizierò
presentandomi quindi Buonasera a tutti
Il mio nome è Marco Veneranda sono un
ragazzo nato e cresciuto ad Ascoli
Piceno e attualmente forno parte di quel
team di ricercatori che si occupa di
gestire le operazioni scientifiche del
perseverance su Marte
ehm sicuramente molti di voi avranno già
sentito parlare del perseverance Infatti
il suo atterraggio su Marte il
cosiddetto ammartaggio ha avuto un
enorme esposizione mediatica
Infatti tanto Dai giornali ai quotidiani
da Facebook a Twitter le immagini e la
mattaggio hanno fatto letteralmente il
giro del mondo però con nostra sorpresa
questo evento ha posto anche noi
ricercatori sotto i riflettori dei media
e vi posso assicurare che qualcosa a cui
non siamo assolutamente abituati
infatti in seguito ad ammartaggio Il mio
telefono è sempre stato letteralmente
subissato di chiamate da parte di
giornali e radio scuole che
all'improvviso volevano organizzare
interviste di incontri
ma è Importante sottolineare che questa
esposizione mediatica si è ritirata con
la stessa velocità con cui ci ha
travolti e se posso essere sincero
questo mi ha lasciato piuttosto
perplesso perché se da un lato è vero
che l'atterraggio la martaggio del Rover
ha rappresentato un momento molto
importante per la ricerca e anche vero
che esso rappresenta solo il primo passo
di questa missione che ve lo posso
assicurare negli anni a venire Ci
riserverà delle grandissime sorprese e
dico questo perché quello che molti non
sanno è che loro equipaggiato una serie
di avanzatissime e strumentazioni che
hanno il compito di analizzare le rocce
su Marte per cercare di identificare
tracce di vita al loro interno infatti
anche se oggi Marte può apparire come un
Ospitaletto rosso sappiamo che negli
anni fa questo pianeta con un aspetto
molto simile alla Terra di oggi in
quanto aveva acqua liquida sulla sua
superficie e un'atmosfera ricca di
ossigeno e il motivo per cui Gesù è
stato selezionato come luogo ideale per
l'ammartaggio del perseverance è che gli
scienziati hanno dimostrato che questo
crateri in realtà rappresenta il fondale
di un antico lago che ormai si è
essiccato è una delle prove che abbiamo
a nostro favore È la foto che vi mostro
in seguito quello che potete vedere in
alto non è altro che il Canyon scavato
nel corso di migliaia di anni dal fiume
che alimentava il lago di Jesolo e
quello che vedete al centro
dell'immagine è il deposito dei detriti
accumulati dal fiume stesso quindi
sapendo che dove c'è acqua C'è vita I
ricercatori sono convinti che il fondare
di questo antico lago possa preservare
le tracce di quegli organismi che
miliardi fa potrebbero aver proliferato
nelle sue acque
ma come potete immaginare cercare vita
in altri pianeti non è semplice questo
perché la strumentazione che a bordo di
un Rover non è comparabile con le
risorse di cui disponiamo noi Nei
laboratori sulla terra ed è per questo
che il perseverance rappresenta solo il
primo tassello di una serie di tre
missioni che hanno il compito di
raccogliere alcune rocce su Marte e
riportarle qui sulla Terra dove potremmo
analizzare il suo fino in fondo e so che
questo può sembrare incredibile ma è la
realtà come spiega questo breve video Le
strumentazioni a bordo del Rover
perseverance sono capaci di
identificare possibili composti organici
che potrebbero conservarsi all'interno
delle rocce Marziane una volta scovate
le cosiddette zone di interesse una
seconda sonda raccoglierà una parte di
queste rocce per poi depositarle
all'interno di contenitori ermetici
una seconda missione poi prevista In un
prossimo decennio invierà un secondo
nome che raccoglierà questi contenitori
li inserirà all'interno di una capsula
che verrà spedita nell'orbita marziana
Finalmente una terza missione coordinata
dalla hesa e dalla NASA manderà un
satellite che raccoglierà questa capsula
dell'orbita marziana e la riporterà
sulla terra grazie a queste missioni il
genere umano avrà quindi finalmente
l'opportunità di dare una risposta a una
delle domande esistenziali per
eccellenza cioè se siamo soli in questo
universo e con un po' di fortuna la
nostra sarà la prima generazione a poter
vedere con i propri occhi possibili
forme di vita provenienti da un altro
pianeta Non vi sembra fantastico
Ma quando parlo di Marte ed esplorazione
spaziale molto spesso mi viene chiesto
chi c'è dietro queste missioni E come si
fa per lavorare in questo campo
Beh a dispetto di quanti molti possono
pensare queste missioni non vengono
interamente sviluppate Nei laboratori
americani della NASA per fare un esempio
la maggior parte degli strumenti che
sono a bordo del perseverance è stata
costruita Grazie al contributo di
istituzioni pubbliche e private come ad
esempio università in aziende che sono
dislocate in tutto il mondo e
concentrandoci solo in Italia sono
numerosissimi ricercatori che lavorano a
questa missione
questo aspetto è molto importante perché
ci fa capire che i successi scientifici
non sono possibili solo grazie ai grandi
luminari della scienza come ad esempio
può essere elon musk il proprietario
della prima azienda spaziale privata
spacex che punta a creare una città su
Marte entro 2050
questi successi Infatti sono possibili
grazie al lavoro di tantissime persone
che sono diverse Tanto per nazionalità
come per formazioni che collaborano per
il raggiungimento di un obiettivo Comune
Quindi ti trasforma questi sogni in
realtà sono migliaia e migliaia di
fisici ingegneri chimici Geologi
informatici molti di quali hanno alle
spalle un percorso che apparentemente
non ha nulla a che vedere con la NASA o
con l'esplorazione spaziale
ad esempio molti di voi in questo
momento stanno pensando che io sia un
astrofisico o un ingegnere aerospaziale
invece sono laureato in scienze per la
conservazione il patrono culturale con
una laurea conseguita proprio qui alla
Ascoli Piceno e fino a 4 anni fa io mi
occupavo di studiare gli affreschi di
Pompei ed anche se la conservazione del
patrimonio culturale e l'esplorazione
marziana sembro Due Mondi totalmente
inconciliabili sono proprio le
competenze acquisite analizzando gli
affetti di Pompei ad averne aperto le
porte nello spazio come potrete
immaginare però lasciare un campo per un
altro non è stato affatto facile ma
quando si è presentato l'occasione ho
deciso di cogliere al volo e dopo tanti
sacrifici e danni di studio sono
riuscito finalmente a formare parte di
quel gruppo di ricercatori che
contribuiscono al funzionamento del
perseverance su Marte ed è importante
quindi che le persone sappiano che per
raggiungere certi obiettivi non c'è
bisogno di avere un'intelligenza
superiore alla media
infatti la qualità più importante è
senza dubbio la determinazione Io ad
esempio Fino all'età di 18 anni sono
stato uno studente piuttosto mediocre
mettiamola così e mi ricordo ancora che
quando disse uno dei miei professori
delle superiori che avevi intenzione di
andare all'università lui si mise a
ridere e mi rispose Ma tu cosa vai a
fare università il bidello
quello che il mio professore è
probabilmente non aveva considerato e
che quando uno studente comune come me
per quanto ho sbagliato possa essere può
ottenere risultati straordinari quando
in lui si accende la scintilla della
passione E questo vale in tutti gli
aspetti della vita ed è per questo che
spero che la mia esperienza sia di
ispirazione per tutti quei ragazzi e
tutte quelle ragazze che provengono una
piccola città come ad esempio la nostra
e che aspirano Qualcosa di grande e del
messaggio che voglio trasmettere di
spingersi oltre la propria zona di
comfort e avere il coraggio e la
rapidità di cogliere l'occasione che si
presentano e di affrontare soprattutto
con passione per la determinazione
combinata con il tuo lavoro può portare
a realizzare i sogni che è il caso
davvero dirlo possono essere davvero
spaziali
Grazie mille